und das alles findet statt an einem tag
nachdem der krieg noch näher an uns
heran gekommen ist wie ein ernster diese
raketeneinschläge am sonntag ganz in der
nähe von lemberg das ist eine
militärbasis dort gewesen 20 kilometer
nur von der nato grenze von der
polnischen grenze entfernt und dort
alleine auf diesem gelände sind gestern
acht russische raketen eingeschlagen die
bilanz mindestens 35 tote dutzende mehr
als 100 verletzte und philipp hof ist
für uns in lemberg genau dort wollen wir
jetzt auch hingehen guten morgens
philipp wir sehen ein sonnenschein und
auch ein fast schon geschäftiges treiben
hinter dir in dieser stadt die er für
viele auch die erste anlaufstelle auf
ihrer flucht geworden ist weil zunächst
dort noch ruhe herrschte das hat sich
aber dann doch deutlich verändert findet
ganz genau gestern kurz vor 6 uhr haben
die explosion gehört und dann war klar
auch lemberg kann jederzeit das ziel von
russischen angriffen werden wir schon
gesagt habe das war eine militärbasis
circa 50 kilometer von lemberg entfernt
und nur 20 kilometer von der polnischen
grenze und heute früh habe ich direkt
mal russisches staats tv also russische
propaganda mir angeschaut und diese
angriff wird dort ausgeschlachtet bis
zum gehtnichtmehr
es wird gesagt dass dort sehr viele
ausländische kämpfer stationiert waren
es wird immer wieder gesagt dass die
nato dort ist vor einigen wochen vogue
rheinische truppen trainiert hat und
ein russischer propagandist hat die
militärbasis als fabrik des
militärischen faschismus bezeichnet und
das ist ganz klar worum es bei diesem
angriff auf die sp war nicht nur ein
militärisches ziel sondern es war auch
eine politische botschaft an den westen
an die nato und zwar wenn ihr die
ukraine weiterhin unterstützt werden wir
eure waffenlieferungen angreifen und
auch eure staatsbürger die in die
ukraine kommen um hier zu kämpfen und zu
helfen hast du denn darüber dass ist in
militärkreisen immer schwierig aber
irgendwelche informationen was dort auf
dem gelände stattgefunden hat denn das
war ja gestern sofort auch ein gerücht
dort liefen möglicherweise oder wurden
die waffenlieferungen abgewickelt rein
in die usa es gab auch eben meldungen
dass dort tatsächlich ausländische
ausbilder eben im einsatz waren für die
ukraine
ich weiß nicht ob schon zeitpunkt des
angriffs noch westliche ausbilder da
waren was wir aber bestätigen können ist
dass ausländische kämpfer da waren also
sogenannte freiwillige ausländische
staatsbürger die sich gemeldet haben die
in die ukraine gekommen sind um zu
helfen dort ist sozusagen der
ausbildungs stützpunkt da waren also
sehr viele von ihm wahrscheinlich
mehrere hundert untergebracht zu diesem
zeitpunkt die ukraine sagt allerdings
ganz klar kein einziger ausländer wurde
verwundet oder getötet
aber die russland hatte er angekündigt
man will es nicht erwarten libyen als
legitime militärische ziele anerkennen
und auch westliche kämpfer natürlich die
russen wollen jetzt selbst so genannte
freiwillige etwa aus syrien her bringt
das sind natürlich ich noch freiwillige
sondern einfach kämpfer söldner die von
russland bezahlt werden aber man will
ganz besonders ein zeichen senden an
alle aus dem westen die hierher kommen
wollen um sich den afghanischen
streitkräften anzuschließen und zwar
sobald gegenüber der grenze seid seid
ihr militärisches ziel für uns dazu auch
dieser angriff da ich nur noch einmal
eingehender auf lemberg auf die stadt
die dahinter liegt das sind bilder die
wir so in den vergangenen wochen nicht
mehr kennen eigentlich menschen die
einkaufen gehen viele menschen auch im
hintergrund wenn die stets vor
menschenleeren straßen gesehen
beschreiben und zu einmal wie die stadt
mit der situation jetzt gerade umgeht
ist das einfach ein aufbäumen wir
gewöhnen uns an den krieg oder nutzt man
tatsächlich ein paar stunden deren er
der ruhe dort beschreibt uns einmal wie
sich das anfühlt in der stadt
ja in lemberg herrscht immer noch eine
gewisse normalität auch eine normalität
von der sehr viele flüchtlinge die aus
dem osten des landes kommen überrascht
sind natürlich positiv überrascht ganz
viele menschen die aus rache oder aus
kiew hier ankommt genießen dass er
zumindest mal eine halbe stunde zu
verschnaufen durch die stadt zu laufen
diesen schönen opernplatz anzuschauen
der hinter mir ist hinter mir ist die
oper von lemberg wir sind total
überrascht dass hier noch das eine oder
andere café geöffnet hat das die
menschen auf die straße gehen dass die
menschen zur arbeit gehen dass die busse
voll also lemberg ist auch trotz des
gestrigen angriffs noch immer die
sicherste stadt der ukraine und die
menschen hoffen natürlich dass das so
bleibt bei ben lemberg auch als sichere
an sicher zufluchtsort wegfällt da haben
die flüchtlinge hier in der ukraine
überhaupt nichts mehr danke philippiak
auf unser bild reporter in lemberg